and now here's my town hall that we
taped earlier today from an airplane
hangar in Green Bay Wisconsin now by the
way we followed all the rules and
recommendations of the county in which
we're doing this so as to have as many
people as they recommended small crowd
but an enthusiastic group of people
obviously because of all that we've been
dealing with with Cove in nineteen we
had a lot of ground to cover tonight
watch this Thank You mr. president
thanks for joining us we're gonna take
some audience questions throughout the
hour you're here in Wisconsin one of the
things everybody's looking for we'll get
into more detail throughout the hours
the economy you are going to leave this
town hall and you're going to announce
that what you're building twenty new
ships you're rebuilding the military and
how many jobs well it's going to be
probably 6,000 7,000 jobs could go up to
10 in Wisconsin alone and it's a great
shipyard that was on hard times and now
it's a very good shipyard and a lot of
people are going to be working and it's
one of the most beautiful ships it looks
like he got with a lot of ammunition on
it I will tell you it's it's really
something and we'll probably end up with
20 or 25 and these are big ones
beautiful ships and they do a beautiful
job in Wisconsin so I'm here it's sort
of like a launch we're starting work and
the contracts all given and you want it
right here so congratulations but we as
a nation we've been watching it was
universal agreement that what happened
at George Floyd should never happen can
never happen again and you've been very
outspoken about it as well but and they
were peaceful protesters but then there
were people rioting we see Anarchy we
see rocks and bottles and bricks and
Molotov cocktails throwing up police
officers police precincts burned to the
ground in Seattle an autonomous zone
that still remains as changing
apparently today but you know taken over
including a police precinct and you're
offering all of these states help New
York Illinois and Washington what are
they telling you when you offer them
help well first of all we have arrested
I think almost but it could be over the
number hundreds of people we have
a lot of people for what they've done
they've created bedlam they've destroyed
very important things I mean you're also
talking about statues of George
Washington Abraham Lincoln they'd like
to get Jesus you know that right they
said we want to get Jesus that's Shawn
King they'd rather you have nothing to
do with any particular event other than
they're troublemakers or agitators and
they're anarchists the big thing they
want is they want to really destabilize
our country and we don't let them so I
said to my people have you've arrested
so many how come we don't know about
they said we don't talk about it so we
do it but I said I think the public
should know it and you know we have a
statues act a monument Act which puts
you in jail for 10 years if you do what
they've done so we've got that we've got
all the tapes because the nice part is
it's all on television like the
character on the horse the other day
he's up there putting on the ropes he's
in trouble on the Andrew Jackson
beautiful it's beautiful right opposite
the White House and you gotta remember
Andrew Jackson the Battle of New Orleans
and so much he was a very good president
he was a great general and you can't let
that happen but thereafter Abraham
Lincoln and tonight I guess they're
looking at Abraham Lincoln and that was
the Emancipation Proclamation so you
have that and you're signing
Emancipation Proclamation and you have
somebody I think that wasn't freed and
he's getting up it's the position of
he's getting up he's being freed by
Abraham Lincoln and I can see
controversy but I can also see beauty in
it and it was paid for by slaves I don't
know if you know that it was paid for
because they were so grateful to the
president it was paid for that reason
and they want to take it down and you
know we can take things down too I can
understand certain things being taken
down but they ought to go through a
process legally and then we take it down
in some cases put them in museums or
wherever they may go
but these are really rioters and they're
a lot of bad people involved you know
they talk about protesters and they're
protesters but there are beyond
protesters too and we're not going to
allow it so we have many many people
under arrest and we have some just from
the other night in Washington but I'm
talking about in other
states also you've offered help to New
york-new me by the way and Washington is
not DC not a state because if I say that
a little statement like that sometimes
I'll say should I correct myself because
the fake news will say he thought DC was
a state so I just want to make that
clear so they can't do it by the way
they do it all the time you know what I
mean let's talk about these states
though you see your old city are now a
Florida resident you're gonna save a lot
of money on taxes I there's there's no
state income tax in Florida but you see
New York City three hundred and fifty
percent increase you see in Chicago last
weekend a hundred and two of our fellow
citizens were shot twelve more children
and fourteen died the carnage existed
all throughout these years that Joe
Biden was vice president Barack was
president I don't know any reforms that
they put in place after Ferguson or
after Baltimore many other incidents
they did virtually nothing and I call
them corrupt Joe he's corrupt and you
look at that administration they have
had more and when you see what's
happening because you saw the notes now
from the oval office meeting and all of
the things we're gonna get to what's
happening is a disgrace this is a
corrupt situation we caught them spying
on my campaign they were spying I said
that a long time ago remember but I said
it without great knowledge it turned out
to be correct they were spying on my
campaign and if that were the other way
around if it was switch with Democrat
and Republican the opposite way you'd
have people in jail for 50 years for
what they did because that's treason
that's a terrible thing what they did
and what they've done to people like
general Flynn and like others is
disgraceful this I want to get back
because I want to stay on this issue
though if we are to become a more
perfect union and if we really want to
pursue happiness we first have to have
law and order correct okay these big
cities we've watched Chicago violence
now for how long
all through the Obama Joe Biden
administration years ago they barely
mentioned it in eight years
you see Seattle you see New York City we
see now people dying in the autonomous
zone
I don't know how people
could pursue their happiness and dreams
in life if they don't have basic
fundamental security you can't you can't
look Chicago is an example it's like
worse than Afghanistan
it's worse than shouldn't sakers they're
working with us Honduras Guatemala
they're all working with us now you know
we have our lowest numbers we have
phenomenal numbers on the border water
patrol has done a great job we built 220
miles of wall it's going up very rapidly
we should be doing about 10 miles a week
now and we're gonna have it'll be
completed very soon but what we've done
there is incredible but you look at
Honduras Guatemala all of these
different places we have cities that are
worse in some cases far worse take a
look at Detroit take a look at what's
happening in Oakland take a look at
what's happening in Baltimore and
everyone gets upset when I say it they
say oh is that a racist statement it's
not a racist frankly black people come
up to me say thank you thank you sir for
saying it they want help these cities
it's like living in hell but last last
week and I think two weeks before that
they shot 14 and 18 people killed and 68
people in Chicago 104 last weekend if
I've ever seen a case I know it's very
controversial to say stop and frisk okay
stop and frisk you take guns away
Chicago is the greatest example I think
I've ever seen of that Rudy Giuliani was
a great mayor he did it in New York he
started it and it worked great
Bloomberg blue and because he went crazy
with it and you know ultimately he took
away a lot of Rights and a lot of it
wasn't a good job he did but Rudy
Giuliani started stop and frisk and he
did a great it was a great thing he did
for New York the murder rate went for
those that don't know how I lived in New
York City at the time went from around
2,500 year they drove it all the way
down to 500 and what they did is they
went into the areas that had the highest
incidence of crime that's right and
saved a lot of lives so we're Americans
I think we can do anything
that optimist if we could stop the
violence right we could stop it quickly
and at some point and they're not too
distant future I'm gonna do it and if
they don't do something with Seattle
we're gonna do that we're gonna go in
there because what's happening is
they're taking over American cities by
the way in all cases it's Democrats the
Democrats run in all cases and Joe Biden
would have that be the whole country
it's so crazy what's happening here's a
guy doesn't talk nobody hears him
whatever he does talk he can't put two
sentences together I don't want to be
nice or uh nice okay but I mean the man
can't speak and he's going to be your
president because some people don't love
me maybe and you know all I'm doing is
doing my job don't forget before the
China plague came in and said China
plague before that came in we had the
best job numbers we've ever had we had
the best economy we've ever had we're
the best stock market we've ever had
which by the way is getting very close
to those numbers anyway and in Nasdaq
it's actually beat those numbers but we
have the best numbers we've ever had
african-american asian-american Hispanic
American women young people without a
diploma young people with a diploma
college everything everything with the
best numbers we've ever had the best
economy we've ever had
I was absolutely doing a number on China
not that I want to but we're taking
billions and billions away China ran
away from us when we had they were gonna
take over a country if I didn't come
along they would have taken over our
country what they did to Obama and Biden
they ripped off this country hundreds of
billions of dollars a year going into
China and nobody said anything they
didn't even talk about it you know it's
not like we had a bad deal with China
it was worse we had no deal they did
whatever and they I get along very well
with them I said how did it happen they
said nobody ever asked nobody said we
gotta make a deal we're taking in
hundreds of billions of dollars worth of
tariffs and we're not paying for him
China's paying for him because they
devalue their currency so we've done an
incredible job
we beat China badly China had the worst
year they've had in 67 years prior to
the plague coming in they had the worst
year they had and
67 years because of the tariffs and all
of the things that I've done but he'll
say he got beated the journey they
didn't do a China deal China ate our
lunch before me and they would have
destroyed our country China in my
opinion would have destroyed our country
economically if I didn't get elected and
many other things coronavirus we did the
ventilators we didn't have any
ventilation we did the ventilators we
did so much ten days after the first
identified case of coronavirus in the
United States right you implemented it a
travel ban followed by a quarantine that
hadn't had happened in 50 years and then
subsequent travel bans Joe said it was
hysteria xenophobic and very
fear-mongering well he didn't say it
they have people that write you know
I'll make a statement it'll be a nice
state but it'll be a little complex or
maybe it's not complex and they will
have that statement analyzed and they'll
say Vice President Biden said and
they'll haven't broken down and I said
he didn't say that he never said
xenophobic because I don't think he
knows what the word means but he said it
was xenophobic it was horrible so I made
the day that was at the end of January
that's very early January 13 and she
Pelosi and many other people repeating
Republicans were months later they were
saying you know let's go to Chinatown
and celebrate Nancy Pelosi was
celebrating in the sever we're in 24th
correct in the streets of Chinatown and
then they you know there's no business
like this they just you could do a great
job like Schumer I did a phenomenal job
on a trade deal and yes and what do you
think of the deal I didn't like it no
good no good he never even saw the deal
it's just like an automatic thing you
hear the sound of that helicopters that
a beautiful sound beautiful sound made
in the USA it's all made in the US you
mentioned earlier my list well beginning
I was a little surprised I'm not gonna
lie they had predicted form a nine and a
half million jobs lost you and we ended
up gaining 2.5 million almost three we
had the largest retail sales month I
don't know if you all saw the numbers 18
percent that's a record so here's my
list
we had a pretty good number come out
today on jobs too well I didn't say that
remember also better than projected but
more importantly so we have more cases
because we do the greatest testing if we
didn't do testing would have no cases
other countries they don't test minions
so up to almost 30 million tests so when
you do 30 min you're gonna have a kid
with the sniffles and they'll say it's
coronavirus whatever you want to call it
I said the other night there are so many
names to this I could name 19 names like
Corona 19 but I could name 19 names but
the fact is that there's never been a
thing like this we've done 30 million
almost we'll be there probably today or
tomorrow 30 million tests now when you
do tests you have cases but what they
don't say is they're fewer deaths than
there have been way way down and our
mortality rate is among the best
countries in the world meaning people
that die because a lot of these tests
it's a case it's a kid doesn't even know
in some cases it's people that didn't
even know they were sick maybe they
weren't but it shows up in a test so
they'll say 30 million tests now you
have a big percentage of that but other
countries do very few tests so it shows
that very few cases and sometimes I
jokingly say or sarcastically say if we
didn't do tests
we'd look great well you know what it's
not the right thing to do treatment
vaccine we're all we so I think the
vaccines are coming along great and I
think the what they call therapeutics
are coming along great and I think we're
gonna have an answer very soon very soon
indeed I think it will be even before
the end of the year we'll have a vaccine
we have great companies and we're
totally mobilized you know military is
doing it we're ready to go as soon as
they have it we will be distributing
that all over the country let me go you
talked about my list earlier so Joe
Biden was vice president for eight years
he has a record that at some point I
assume somebody might have to ask him or
maybe you will when you debate him if he
shows up which is a question we will
find out in the future but 13 million
more Americans after eight years were on
food stamps 8 million more in poverty
the lowest labor participation rate
since the 70s worse recovery since the
40s lowest homeownership rate in 15
years now I look at your record for pre
coronavirus we had
record after record low unemployment
with every with african-americans
Hispanic Americans you noblest
even african-american youth unemployment
and I want to get to the issue because
it it seems like if we look in compare
and contrast historically black colleges
a five-year commitment with more money
than ever before Opportunity Zones I
think one of the biggest changes in
terminal just a little criminal justice
reform
well the biggest in criminal justice
reform Obama and Biden never even tried
it and that was something so important
for the black community they came to me
they were they wanted it so badly
because it is it's a very unfair
situation and they came I dare to
minorities especially minorities and
especially black and Hispanic it's so
unfair and I said why wasn't this done
before
now Obama didn't try if he did he make
him I said we did try but you know he
didn't get it done I got it done people
said you wouldn't be able to get it done
I got it done with the help of some very
good Republicans that frankly they could
have gone either way on it to be honest
although we had some very strong
conservative Republicans like Mike Lee
Republicans that wanted it very much
Chuck Grassley some great strong
conservative Republicans that wanted it
very much so it you know it's both ways
very unusual yet some very strong
conservatives and you also had some
really really liberal people but we did
criminal justice reform nobody thought
it was possible to get it done I got it
done they couldn't get it done and then
they'll say such horrible things I mean
on the campaign they'll say such
horrible things about me it's a very
unfair business but the end he did this
more it's a great end for them I got
beaten by China wrong I beat China very
badly way I got I didn't do this
a coronavirus might take Joe's side
though because I don't think your son
got 1.5 billion dollars that's right
that's right
the wave looked over okay nobody's ever
seen anything like that but what they'll
do is they'll take five or six points
and just say I lost and if you look at
what we've done on ventilators on
testing again where we have 30 million
Germany is
and with maybe four maybe five million
so Germany's going to show fewer cases
because they're testing far fewer people
different sized countries and all but
they're testing far fewer people but
many countries don't do testing like
that so chose we will weigh up in
testing but what it also shows by doing
that in all fairness it shows a very
very low mortality rate just about the
lowest so we're right at the bottom in a
positive way and I think that people are
starting to see it but if I don't do a
show like this you know which is live or
semi live if I don't do a show like this
it will be we're not going to get the
word out because the press is really
corrupt and dishonest I can't believe it
I used to say you know fake news faked
us it's much worse than factious and
it's not only what they say it's what
they don't say yeah something great
could be happening and they refuse to
report it
you mentioned general Flynn we saw Peter
struck snow it's now a lot of it was
redacted idly and I my sources have been
telling me and this program weeks that
I've devoted almost three years to UM
peeling every layer of the onion in fact
what we now know is that there was that
Jack Flynn was exonerated the case was
going to be closed then Joe Biden
brought up the Logan Act which you
mentioned earlier $17.99 law nobody's
ever been prosecuted for now not only
was it that we've now learned that there
was premeditated fraud on a FISA Court
to spy on you as a candidate you and
your transition team and deep into your
presidency and James Comey signed three
of the four warrants but he came to you
after he signed the first one in Trump
Tower and said well again now we know
the bulk of information was Hillary's
dirty Russian disinformation dossier
made a lot of money for she paid for it
they knew it they said they had verified
it and turned out to be all untrue but
it ended up for you to be in the country
a three-year nightmare I question though
is this I mean general Flynn lost four
years of his life right Roger stones
supposed to report to jail and the jury
foreperson in his case
palmat affords case was dead and they
and many people that work for you pay
how much in lawyers fees over this lie
so start in reverse order Paul Manafort
they sent in a book it looked like he
got all sorts of cash it turned out to
be a fraud what they did to that man
what they did to Paul might afford Roger
stone what they've done to Rajasthan
because he knew me he wasn't on the
campaign except the very very beginning
what they did with Roger stone what they
did to general Flynn and how about
Papadopoulos I didn't know Papadopoulos
but what they put him through he turned
out to be totally they had a tape of his
conversation that was supposed to be
this conversation was like a perfect
conversation they also have a tape of
Flynn's conversation with the Russian
ambassador which is a normal thing to do
you're going to have that position you
start calling up because you want to
coordinate between countries and the
tape was as I you said with the Russia
with the Ukrainian situation it was a
perfect tape it was a perfect
conversation that he had what they've
done to Jay to general Flynn who's a
nice man tough guy smart guy a great
general I'll tell you general Milley
said he's one of the finest people
dealings it's just a good man Flint what
happened to him the way they went after
him and if you remember you remember
well the FBI left I said he did nothing
wrong they said he didn't lie
they didn't say like they said he didn't
like they persecuted he threatened to
put his son and go after a son they said
to me what was the toughest friends of
mine what's the toughest country to deal
with who is it is it China is it Russia
could it be North Korean no it's the
United States of America the toughest
country to deal with because we have
Schumer and Pelosi and people that are
bad people that I honestly believe don't
love our country what they do to our
country and what they've done with this
scam the whole scam Flynn is a piece of
it the Muller scam now it came out that
Muller should have announced in the
first week that we did nothing wrong in
other words they had evidence in the
first few days that there was no
collusion with Russia there was nothing
to do with Russia they knew that
immediately he didn't have to take two
or two-and-a-half years
they knew it immediately what they put
this country through Jeff Sessions was a
disaster he was a total disaster
because he basically let it happen
unknowingly because he's not very smart
but they let it happen and and it's a
shame what they put this country through
mm-hmm as you look we now have a Durham
report we now had the Inspector General
report I would imagine that's probably
going to be indictments at the end of
this when you look at the names of the
people for example the jury foreperson
and Roger stones case was prejudiced
against that was not a fair no key moral
even can you believe it the hatred that
she had for him and for me and you and
she said oh no I don't know she acted
like she was an innocent she ran for
Congress or something and lost but she
was like pretending to be an innocent
how did she even get into the jury pool
she must have had a little contact but
and the judge who's been brutal the
judge who sentenced roger has been
brutal take a look at what she's done to
people same judge in the matter for case
well take a look at what she did for
Hilary late related things okay
wasn't brutal there but look at what
what she did to people just take a look
at what she has done and Roger stone had
a jury foreman for woman who was a
disaster how that's not declared a
mistrial or more than a mistrial is
incredible to anybody that sees it this
is a person that hated Roger stone hated
me and obviously said wonderful things
otherwise she couldn't have gone and it
looks like he reports to jail I believe
in four days yeah
are you thinking about a pardon already
I don't want to get in on your face but
I think he was treated very unfairly
clearly though other than he may have
been about very early on and I've known
him for a long time but I've known him
like everybody in Washington know him
you have a lot of guys in Washington
they do he was not involved in the
campaign maybe a little bit at the very
very beginning but he wasn't invite was
at a part of the campaign but he's a
professional they've destroyed his life
totally destroyed his life what they've
done to Roger stone is incredible and
the jury forewoman stands out and to
have at least not give him
a new trial is inconceivable and by the
way she was a dominant person the juror
says she was very dominating in the room
she dominated he got a tremendously big
sentence you see these guys they're
burning down buildings they're ripping
down statues they're hurting police they
don't go to jail nothing happens to him
they give they wanted to give him 9
years in jail process crime yeah if that
if that and then you have these
prosecutors who were Muller related the
whole Muller related thing one friend
said to me you have to be the most
innocent man in the history of the
United States I had 18 angry Democrat
geniuses all smart smarter Zell Muller
lost it but they were all smart as hell
all these guys were after me
they spent 45 4955 I hear all different
numbers million dollars over a period of
two and a half years and they got
nothing on me it was I think I am the
probably friend of mine said you have to
be the most perfect person they had
everybody up to we'll take a break we'll
come back as we continue from Great
Green Bay Wisconsin also the president
will be answering your questions as we
continue stay with us
all right welcome back we are in Green
Bay Wisconsin all right the audience has
some questions for the president we're
gonna start from Linda hi Linda from
Wausau Wisconsin thank you for being
here with us today say a lot of
presidents trouble windows right windows
you know I bought a lot of Wausau
windows over the years and you know it's
I shouldn't give him a free commercial
but they did a good job it's a great
window
they are Wisconsin I love it up here
Thank You Nora Senor Presidente my Cuban
background to it I have a question for
you I appreciate so much what you have
done for this country and I know it's
been tough what do you think is your
greatest accomplishment in your eyes so
a lot of people think it's the fact that
we will have I think before I'm finished
this term we'll have close to 300 judges
federal judges a lot of people think
because that's a record that's a number
that nobody can even believe and part of
it was that President Obama was unable
to get judges approved in a large number
about 142 judges so I took it off got
them approved and then got a lot of
proved beyond so will be close to 300
and two Supreme Court judges grade ones
and so I think a lot of people would say
that I think one of them oh is our
military we have space force which we've
added after 76 years we've added a new
branch of the military it's a big deal a
very important deal because space is
going to be very important it already is
I would say the rebuilding of the
military and the taking care of our vets
we had a 91% Chone approval rating the
other day the VA the VA was a disaster
all of my life I've seen these horror
stories I don't want to I don't want to
really jinx it because they'll go around
find somebody that's unhappy but you
don't see that anymore
and our administrator or Secretary has
done a fantastic job and we're 91
percent approval rating with the VA and
we got veterans Choice approved and
veterans accountability that's where you
can fire people that do a bad job you
couldn't do it before very hard to get
they tried to get it for 50 years
because the civil service unions etc
couldn't you know get it I got it
and the other thing
is veteran choice where if they can't
see a doctor we have great doctors in
the VA but if you can't see a doctor you
go out and you get a private doctor we
pay the bill and it's you have no idea
how great it's been and it's actually
you saved money believe it or not but
you have no idea we save lives
tremendous number of lives and I would
say that's an achievement but you know
we've done a lot with the largest tax
cuts ever the largest regular if you
look at our regulation cuts shown more
than any other Administration in history
whether it's eight years or in one case
more than that we cut regulations and we
have we still have a lot more we're
going to be cutting over the next month
and a half two months so we've done a
lot and we're very proud of it and we
had the best you know until this
artificial problem because I call it an
artificial problem we had a turn over
our country to save millions of lives
and now we've turned it back on and it's
coming back much faster than anybody
thought possible so we've done a lot of
things but you know it could be judges
could be the military thank you thank
you
two questions question I get asked most
often I said about the people that love
and support you they want to know why
you fight so hard with the media why do
you fight against the why do you come
you know you take on anybody that that
goes on and you answer this
interestingly in the Martha and Brett
town hall and for those that say well
maybe you shouldn't fight on all these
issues what do you say I don't think I
have a choice if I didn't take on the
media I guarantee I wouldn't be here
with you tonight I'd be watching on
television maybe I'd be in the crowd but
I'd be watching I wouldn't be I wouldn't
be interviewed you couldn't win and I
haven't even to this day I mean every
the New York Times is so dishonest the
Washington Post is so dishonest they
write things you can do something great
and they can make it sound horrible
you can do something good and they can
make it sound beyond belief bad like
it's the worst thing ever or and I said
it a little bit before you can do
something great and it doesn't get
reported that's in a way just as bad
because a lot of people can figure it
out the level of dishonesty in the media
is I think they're the most dishonest
people I've ever dealt with no not
everybody you have honest you're not
honest journalists you're a great
journalist you know we have great
journalists look at the Pulitzer Prize
the Pulitzer Prize is very embarrassed
if you lost a lot of its credibility
because all these writers got Pulitzer
Prizes on the Russia Russia Russia and
they were all wrong but John Solomon and
all of the people that you that you deal
with and you by the way
Laura Lou Dobbs you Fox and Friends
people that a great great group in the
morning including the weekends to be
honest with Pete but but you have some
great people but they got Pulitzer
Prizes on Russia Russia Russia and they
were wrong now committee should be went
right on the deep state they were wrong
no you were every year they were wrong
for three were right on Ukraine the
Ukraine thing was a hoax is a pure hoax
they took a pic of it they impeached a
duly elected President of the United
States on a perfect conversation
actually there were two conversations
the first one was hello goodbye they
don't even talk about that the second
one was about the same thing they
impeached a President of the United
States now no fairness the Republican
Party was great because he got 196 to
nothing Republican votes in the House
and 52 and a half to a half Romney
Romney to bear but he half of you know I
call it 50 to it I have to AF because he
had two votes one was yes but we did
that they were great the Republican
Party was great but they were steadfast
because they knew it was a hoax it was
purely a party line impeachment nothing
like that's ever happened before to add
to that they had to ignore Joe on tape
saying you're not getting the billion
unless your fire the prosecutor
investigating my zero experience on
making millions but what that said Jim
is with us from beautiful Wisconsin hey
Jim Thank You Sean
mr. president and welcome to Green Bay
Wisconsin in Northeast Wisconsin thank
you great to have you with us my
question for
you is with all the unrest we've seen
across the country and right here in the
state of Wisconsin last night in our
capital city yes a senator was beaten
lady forward was ripped off her pedestal
we lost some other statues what steps is
the administration taking to give us
back our streets so very strong you
happen to have a Democrat governor right
now if you would have had Governor
Walker that wouldn't have happened
that's what happened but it did happen
and it was a shame and the person they
beat up was a Democrat who happened to
be gay and he was probably out there
rooting them on or something because
Democrats think it's wonderful that
they're destroying our country it's a
very sick thing going on nobody's ever
seen it
Biden is is going to be look I don't
think Biden's a radical left but it
doesn't matter because they're gonna
just do whatever they want to do they'll
take him over he can't he can't perform
he's not gonna be able to perform he's
shot he's shot whether you like it or
not he shot the radical left is going to
take him over look what happened eliot
engel was a pretty mainline guy he lost
by like 37 points or so yet just he just
got killed in the election we just had
yesterday he was supposed to be a
shoo-in and he got hit by a strong
far-left
candidate you have a couple of other
Congress men and women that probably are
gonna lose or are going to lose very
close too close to call look at what's
happened to the Democrats and these are
real lefties these are people that that
take a look at Venezuela Venezuela was a
very rich country a great country a
beacon 20 years ago 15 years ago people
looked richest country in Latin South
America richest everything good they
don't have food they don't have water
they have death all over people have
nothing it's the same exact mindset and
philosophy that we have today on attack
and it won't happen not while I'm here
it won't happen but a guy like Biden
he's gonna have no power to do anything
about it
and they're dragging him I don't know if
you saw Bernie Sanders said my sole
focus now is to take Joe Biden way left
they going to do it because there's
nobody in the center left funny where he
was left anyway but there's nobody in
the center or center left I mean it's
it's a disgrace what's happened to a
country now with that being said the
Republicans have to get tougher and I'm
telling them all the time because
they're sitting back they want to be
politically correct I think oh it's
terrible to say something bad no no no I
told them you'll see if anyone attacks I
stopped at the other night I stopped it
a number of times but you'll see what's
happening and we told him every night
we're gonna get tougher and tougher and
at some point there's gonna be
retribution because there has to be
these people of vandals but they're
agitated but they're really terrorists
in a sense so I think you'll be
extremely impressed but you have to put
pressure also I love the Republicans I
told you they came for me a hundred
percent I'm at 96 percent approval
rating in the Republican Party but I
said you're gonna have to get tougher
you can't be politically correct anymore
because we're really fighting something
that's very dangerous
thank you let's talk about a second term
if you here in 131 days from now at some
point in the night or early morning we
can now project Donald J Trump has been
reelected the 45th President of the
United States let's talk howdy what's at
stake in this election as you compare
and contrast and what is one of your top
priority items for a second term well
one of the things that will be really
great you know the word experience is
still good I always say talent is more
important that experience I've always
said that but the word experience is a
very important word it's an a very
important meeting I never did this
before I never slept over in Washington
I was in Washington I think 17 times all
of a sudden the president the United
States you know the story of riding down
Pennsylvania Avenue with our first lady
and I say it's as great but I didn't
know very many people in Washington
wasn't my thing I was from Manhattan
from New York now I know everybody and I
have great people in the administration
you make some mistakes
like you know an idiot like bolton only
want to do his drop bombs on everybody
you don't have to drop bombs on
everybody you have to kill people judges
you have john bolton in fact released
classified material should he be
prosecuted yeah oh absolutely well he
did release classified actually he had a
a judge said that they released the book
early so that he couldn't do he said he
couldn't start he said this is very
dangerous what you've done for yourself
and also any money that you've made
that's you know good luck this was a
very powerful opinion that we had no
he's sort of a sick guy there's
something wrong with him but i noticed
that earlier he made two very bad
mistakes he made a mistake where he
talked about the libyan model and I
won't go to explain that but some of you
understand he was on defaced the nation
and he talked about the Libyan model I
said that's a disaster because you know
why and the other thing he said going
into Iraq was a good thing I said okay
job but now you know it wasn't right no
no I still think it was I said so
weren't for eight trillion dollars in
the Middle East and you think that was a
good thing and I'm pulling out you know
I'm getting everybody out nice and easy
everyone's going nicely going nicely you
think it was good to go into Iraq go
into the Middle East yes
so those two things happen too early in
his little period of time he was only
there a short while once he said those
two things
I no longer paid much attention to him
if any but I'll tell he was good for one
thing everyone thought he was crazy cuz
only wants to do his bomb people you
know he'll fight Russia let's fight
Russia let's fight China let's take them
on at the same time he's crazy when I
walked into a room with him I knew that
when they saw Bolton they always gave me
what I wanted cuz they said Trump's
gonna drop bombs on me he's got this
maniac with him so in a way he helped me
in terms of a negotiation but seriously
he was he didn't do a good job he wasn't
smart he wasn't sure and he's the only
man I think I've ever met I known for a
year one year whatever the time it was
short time I don't think I ever saw him
smile once I said to him once John do
you have a smile and it tells you
something about somebody you still be
back to caliphate
he got back daddy and associates you got
Soleimani you got the cattle kinda
leader and Yemen we've done a lot so
back yeah we took out Salome need number
one terrorists in the world we took out
al Baghdadi he was also considered
number one I guess they fought for a
number when I got him both Obama should
have gotten L beg daddy but we took them
both out well we took a hundred percent
of the Caliphate when I took it over it
was all over the place it was a desert
it's the Isis Caliphate it won't be on
your second term agenda to drop cargo
planes the cache of mullahs in Iran I'm
just guessing like 1.8 billion in green
beautiful cash but in cash 1.8 but I
think was five plane loads of cash by
plane was cargo 1.8 billion and 150
billion actually I was more impressive
with 1.8 billion in cash if you want to
know that truth so it was one of those
things
mark Wisconsin hey Mark how are you
tomorrow well looking forward to your
sex like Bolton but a better-looking
version look I could do much better
looking I could do is I think looking
forward to your second term I thank you
a big concern I've got is how are you
going to make sure that the election is
fair and free from from fraudulent apps
and T votes and mail-in ballots that's
the concern I've got I think it's the
most important question I'll be asked
because it's a great question so now we
have a mail-in thing as you see
California he's sending out millions and
millions of ballots where are they going
where aren't they going is the postman
going to hand them out are they going to
take them out of the mailboxes the other
thing mark it's very important you get a
foreign country Souter they keep talking
old Russia China this especially China
not Russia especially China are they
going to print millions of ballots using
the exact same paper using the exact
same machines and are they going to
print ballots and then hand them in and
all of a sudden it's the biggest risk we
have the mail-in ballot not so much the
absentee ballot because an absentee like
I'm in the White House and I have to
vote in Florida etc it's after your
absentee it's okay but people go through
a process for that you know they it's
really pretty good but the mail-in
ballots they mail up to anybody and
they send them out by the millions I
think I read over 30 million ballots are
gonna be sent out in California where
are they going
nobody's standing here watching you vote
at least the other way you get in line
and they're using you know I said the
other day we went through World War one
and we voted we went through World War
two and we voted and now we have a virus
and by that time it'll be less and less
why aren't we going to vote people want
to vote but it would be nice to be able
to see the people and on top of that
they should have ID voting okay
we should have ID ballot a particularly
great question you said you would like
to have more than three debates with Joe
Biden I said I'll have three and any
amount they want I didn't say I want
more see if you say you want more just
to show what a tricky business is I want
more they'll say oh he feels he's losing
you once more so don't like to say that
I will do whatever number they want to
do it's okay with me but a matter of
three yeah I guess the three is the
minimum now he's already saying that he
can't do the debates because of kovat
you believe it I can't do it the debates
because of covered that was I just heard
a little inkling of it two days ago I
said watch this one no I won't do any
amount of debates you understand what I
mean if I said I want to do ten debates
they'll say oh he's afraid he's afraid
he's gonna lose no no what I want to do
is I'll do two three and I'll do any
amount that they want it doesn't make
any difference to me he is a candidate
that will destroy this country and he
may not do it himself he will be run by
a radical fringe group of lunatics that
will destroy our country and people have
to know that